k
[Música]
Olá minhas amigas meus amigos sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live Feliz ano novo a todos Espero que
vocês tenham tido excelentes festas de
final de ano excelentes
entradas e vamos esperar o melhor para
esse ano apesar dos pesares né pelo
menos uma boa
notícia eu fiquei sabendo agora
hoje Aparentemente o mar Zuckerberg tá
seguindo os passos do Elo musk não
porque ele adora a liberdade de
expressão mas porque provavelmente ele
percebeu que tava tendo prejuízos com a
política de censura da Meta ele tá dando
um passo para trás e isso teve uma
grande repercussão não sei se
vocês acompanharam isso daí nas mídias
hoje então a grande notícia de hoje pelo
menos uma boa notícia que se isso virar
moda né quem sabe a gente consegue menos
censura no YouTube
segir os passos també da met também da
do e
vão parar aí de censurar né boa noite
Ana Paula Boa noite Alexandre Boa noite
Carlos n que é Maria Helena
Eloí Luciana
estel se bemos umb por de como udio
estou usando o microfone profissional só
que ele tá um pouquinho longe da minha
boca el tá aqui nessa direção aqui mas
eu acredito que o áudio esteja bom né é
um microfone da shur que eu comprei há
pouco tempo
e a minha ideia é utilizar esse
microfone pro pros meus vídeos futuros
aqui só que como eu fixei ele na mesa de
uma maneira para não atrapalhar os
monitores ele não fica tão pé na minha
boca mas quando eu for gravar os vídeos
eu vou virar o mofone pro outro lado e
aí vai ficar melhor obrigado pelo
feedback Estela Mares temos a d Ana
Paula
hoje acompanhando Nossa Live Espero que
ela fique até o final né E aí vocês
podem dirigir perguntas a
ela bem pessoal temos aqui algumas
perguntas deixa eu dividir a tela com
vocês o stream ard mudou um pouquinho
aqui a o layout deles
prefiro redondinho vou colocar num
redondinho só que eles mudaram aqui ó
Prontinho Ah mas tá Rosinha esse negócio
aqui era para tá Rosinha
mesmo deixar nessa cor
aqui
ah deixa eu mudar a cor aqui pera
aí eles Mexeram na configuração Deixa
assim mesmo depois vamos mexe na
cor muito bem a primeira
pergunta o sen o senhor teria alguma
indicação de filtro solar com fator de
verão ultravioleta a 20 no mínimo sem
parabenos ou até mesmo
vegano
Sim eu anotei aqui algumas
marcas tem uma marca que preenche os
critérios aí que você quer é o equilibre
Amazônia equilibre com K equilíbrio e
Amazônia tem um fator de proteção uva 28
que corresponde de FPS 30 é 100% natural
e vegano é livre de parabenos e
substâncias
sintéticas indicado para todos os tipos
de pele e não deixa a pele esbranquiçada
tenho também o creamy deixa eu anotar
primeiro aqui no bate-papo essas
marcas tô colocando aqui no bate-papo e
vou mostrar para vocês aqui tá e
equilibre Amazônia essa primeira marca
que eu
comentei aí tem o
[Música]
crime esse crime ele tem um fator de
proteção
uva 25 e o fps
60 é vegano tem um toque seco de rápida
absorção e promove proteção contra a luz
azul e visível tem uma outra maca chama
fotoequilíbrio
e dá para fazer manipular também tá como
Tana Paula tá comentando
aqui essa foto equilíbrio tem o fator de
proteção vaa 20 o FP 60 é vegano não tem
parabeno é resistente à água
hipoalergênico tá então desses todos aí
o que tem maior proteção uva é o
equilíbrio
esse aqui que eu
mostrei ele possui uma relação fator de
proteção vaa FPS alta de 28 para
30 e tem
o a característica de ser 100% natural
não contém nenhum tipo de ingrediente
sintético que possa causar
irritação deixa colocar aqui as
observações D Ana Paula
Se for para melas vão passar a cada 4
horas pode associar protetor com
hidratantes para firmeza e linhas
finas aguardando e-mail Não entendi essa
não Ana você explica
aí bem vamos continuar aqui
quando se faz uso de prasterona pessoa
colocou pasterona mas tem um R aqui tá
prasterona pode mudar para dha ou Existe
algum protocolo para realizar mudança E
qual seria mais eficiente dha Ou
prasterona eles são exatamente iguais
tá eles são exatamente a mesma
substância na
verdade Aconteceu uns do anos atrás é
que essa massa de manipulação
conseguiram
a liberação da Anvisa para prasterona só
que o de Até hoje ainda é proibido a sua
importação pelo menos oficialmente
né então não tem por fazer nenhum
protocolo de mudança porque é a mesma
substância Ok Lembrando que o Deia ou
prasterona ele é convertido no corpo
para vários outros hormônios é um
precursor hormonal ele vai virar
primeiro
androstenediona de androstenediona ele
vai virar testosterona E aí ele pode
virar também estradiol ou estrona então
tem que tomar cuidado porque de acordo
com os seus com as suas
enzimas essa conversão ela pode ser
maior ou menor né então tem que ficar
muito atento aos outros hormônios que
são filhos né são derivados do
dhea e o dha tem uma minha vida curta de
ser de 1 a 3 horas mas ele é convertido
em sulfato de Deia que dura muito mais
tempo dura de 10 a 20 horas
tá e as formas de administração do Deia
barra prasterona via oral é mais comum
na verdade para mulher eu passo por
volta de 10 a 20 MG para homens eu passo
em torno de 25 a 50 mg para doença
autoimune a gente usa doses mais altas
aí mas tem mais efeitos colaterais né
mas para doença atim você pode usar 100
a 200 mg ele é interessante para
melhorar a densidade óssea melhorar o
sistema imune melhorar a
memória ele atua também na musculatura
então tem vários efeitos interessantes
aí na mulher pode ser feito por via
vaginal por óvulos ou gel transvaginal e
pode ser utilizado também em gel
transdérmico Então existe a forma de
você utilizar udia vaginal ou udia na
coxa
transdérmico e tem muita gente que
prefere usar cim do que usar vi oral
você vê que eu não tenho geralmente
problemas usando vi oral
não e tem muitas mhas que reclamam
quando faz via transvaginal fica muito
melecado ela sente coceira então Elas
preferem usar às vezes transdérmico na
coxa ou via
oral bem vamos pra próxima
pergunta o que que o senhor recomenda no
sentido de Minimizar os efeitos da
grande altitude pra pessoa que vai ao
Peru bem o que os locais fazem eu acho
que vocês conhecem né eles mascam
coca então se você quiser uma solução
simples seria mascar coca agora Digamos
que você não queira por vários motivos
né Apesar de que mascar Coca não é uma
coisa que a curto prazo vai gerar algum
problema maior Mas pode ser que você não
queira por algum motivo mascar coca né
até pro nojo não gosta do Sabor e tudo
mais
né então o primeiro ponto aqui tem que
tomar muita água para manter a
hidratação outra coisa pode fazer é
tomar chá de gengibre Ele é bem útil
puler antiinflamatório e antioxidante
ajuda a reduzir inflamação e ajuda a
melhorar a circulação sanguínea que você
vai precisar num ambiente de alta
atitude porque nesse ambiente de alta
altitude Você pode ter dor de cabeça e
náusea por conta da saturação de
oxigênio ser mais baixa e você não tá
acostumado
ok também pode utilizar o chá de hortelã
pimenta tem efeitos analgésicos e
relaxantes vai ajudar a aliviar a tensão
muscular estimular a atividade
respiratória e evitar esforços físicos
intensos primeiros dias que você tiver
lá no peru Então tenta fazer uma
aclimatação de TRS qu dias antes de você
resolver fazer alguma trilha caminhada
longa Ok para você não ficar passando
mal não consuma álcool ou evite pelo
menos o consumo excessivo de álcool e
também de cafeína isso ajuda a reduzir o
sintomas próxima pergunta quando se
utiliza ldn em baixas doses também é
necessário fazer o desmame não é
necessário OK
o ldn já é baixíssima a dosagem então
não tem necessidade de fazer o
desmame Lembrando que o ldn que é o low
na altrex ou naxa de baixa
dosagem ele é utilizado na dosagem
habitual de 1,5 a 4,5 MG por dia é uma
dose muito mais baixo que as doses
habituais de 50 a 300 mg por dia só que
na dose 50 300 mg é para pessoas que têm
vício em drogas ou em álcool então é
para tirar a pessoa do vício do álcool
ou de drogas especialmente as
drogas derivadas do ópio Ok quando você
usa o ldn que de 1,5 a 4,5 você tá
tratando doença autoimune você tá
utilizando como antidepressivo você tá
utilizando ele como imunomodulador tá
utilizando ele como anticâncer tá
utilizando ele como tratamento de dor
modulador da dor então tem várias
funções
aí e aí nessa dosagem Não há necessidade
nenhuma de você fazer o desmame
ok próxima
pergunta me disseram que fazer chá de
uma erva e deixar essas folhas dentro do
chá os princípios ativos Retornam pra
folha nunca ouvi falar nisso viu Maria
Helena
né nunca ouvi falar isso pesquisar né
porque como eu nunca tinha ouvido
falar e o que eu
pude observar da minha busca é que não é
verdade que esses princípios ativos vão
voltar pra folha tá até seria meio
bizarro isso daí no meu ponto de vista
Então quando você faz o chá com evas os
princípios ativos seja óleos essenciais
seja flavonoides seja ter pena seja o
que for esses compostos benéficos eles
vão ser extraídos da Eva vão ser
dissolvidos na água
e ele não vai voltar pra
folha por exemplo é o caso do chá de
hortelã pimenta que eu comentei agora a
pouco o ácido rosmarínico dele e os
flavonoides vão ser extraídos da folha e
vão permanecer na água do chá não vai
acontecer isso que você tá falando aí aí
de voltar pra folha não eu não sei onde
você se você tiver ao vivo Me diz onde
que você viu isso que eu nunca tinha
visto essa
afirmação bem Essa foi a última pergunta
agora eu
vou falar para vocês de alguns artigos
interessantes mas antes deixa eu mostrar
aqui a comentário da Ana Paula boa noite
ruberg um abraço para
você existe foto proteção oral sim você
pode tomar uma cápsula luteína
picnogenol e
leucotomos boa noite Letícia Obrigado
por est aqui presente com
gente Papai Noel bonzinho não entendi
esse comentário aqui Estela ah Estela
Estela me convidou para fazer uma
maratona não uma corrida curta né mas eu
tô ainda meio fora de forma viu Estela
Mas eu acho que daqui uns dois ou três
meses eu vou est pronto para fazer essa
corrida tô pegando muito firme agora
desde 15 dias atrás na atividade física
não posso mais bobear como eu já
aconteceu algumas vezes até me inscrevi
em academia de bacana para ver se eu
ficou com raiva da mensalidade aí eu vou
mais
vezes aquelas academias que tem um monte
de de aula que nunca fiz na minha vida
né V ver se eu consigo fazer agora essas
aulas malucas de b não sei o quê
eh body combat b não se das contas
espacial essas coisas aí vamos ver se
eu se eu consigo pegar gosto pela coisa
aí não vou ficar só na musculação vou
ver se eu faço umas coisas diferentes
esse ano
aí muito bem vamos discutir os artigos
aqui
bem pessoal você já devem ter ouvido
falar que os
antibióticos poderiam estar relacionados
a formação de pedra nos íes eu acho que
vocês não escutaram isso né mas tem
estudos recentes que sugerem que o uso
de antibióticos como conhecido
cefazolina que é muito usado como
antibiótico preventivo de cirurgia né
antibiótico profilaxia esses
antibióticos podem causar desequilíbrios
na microbi R bem estão discutindo agora
sobre microbiota renal não apenas a
microbiota intestinal oral ou até mesmo
da beiga agora est falando de microbiota
do rim então esses antibióticos podem
favorecer o crescimento bactérias
associadas à formação de cálculos
renais Então vamos entender melhor essa
conexão intrigante o impacto dos
antibióticos na SA dos
revelam que antibióticos podem perturbar
o da microbiota nos ins deixa eu mudar
aqui
a minha imagem aqui
pronto pesquisa revela que antibióticos
então podem perturbar o equilíbrio da
microbiota nos rins reduzindo bactérias
benéficas como é o caso do lactobacilos
que é os mesmos benéficos lá do
intestino e promovendo o crescimento das
enterobacter suas enterobactérias
que possam estar se desenvolvendo na
urina enquanto que os lactobacilos
ajudam a degradar o Oxalato né que é o
principal componente de pedras junto com
o cálcio então o lactobacilos vai
proteger contra formação de cristais de
Oxalato essas outras bactérias do Mal as
enterobacteria aumentam a cristalização
e favorece a formação de
pedras então abertas destacam como o uso
de antibióticos pode impactar a
microbiota sensível dos zins em modelos
experimentais antibióticos alteraram
significativamente as bactérias
presentes e criaram um ambiente mais
propenso a formação de cálculos então
isso vai reforçar a necessidade de
cautela no uso de
antibióticos considerando Impacto a
longo prazo na saúde renal Então as
pedras noin como eu comentei rapidamente
mas vou me aprofundar um pouco mais
agora elas são principalmente formadas
por cristais de Oxalato de Calcio
Oxalato mais o
cálcio esses oxalatos eles são
encontrados em alimentos como espinafre
batata doce então eles são derivados de
algumas plantas eles são considerad
antinutrientes como é o caso dos
fitatos como é o caso do do glúten
Ok então esses oxalatos eles podem
formar cristais afiados quando
combinados com cálcio especialmente se
houver alterações no metabolismo e
desequilíbrio na microbiota intestinal e
renal então além dos fatores dietéticos
a destruição de bactérias protetoras do
intestino e nos rins e tem uma conexão
entre um e outro devido ao uso
prolongado de antibióticos pode aumentar
a presença de oxalatos na urina isso
ressalta a importância de manter um
microbioma saudável e assim reduzir o
risco de
cálculos Então como é que a gente faz
para manter essa microbiota equilibrada
que seria uma estratégia muito eficaz
para prevenir pedras no zins seria
também através de uso de prebióticos né
você comer uma variedade bem grande de
verduras coloridas e a inclusão de
probióticos como é o caso lactobacilos
na dieta Então você comer alimentos
fermentados isso poderia ajud dar a
restaurar as bactérias benéficas os
lactobacilos então evitar alimentos
Ultra processados como tô cansado de
falar aqui e minimizar o uso de
antibiótico seriam Passos importantes
para proteger a saúde renal E além disso
tem várias estratégias como aumento na
ingestão de água controle do consumo de
oxalatos e manutenção na dieta
equilibrada para quem tem essa
facilidade de uma Pedras tem que
restringir alimentos se inclus oxalatos
tem terapias naturais que você já
conhece que já tem vídeos no canal como
o uso de dmso ou de metil sulfóxido e
isso mostrou resultados promissores na
dissolução de cálculos em estudos
iniciais oferecendo alternativas seguras
Então
dmso já não bastar essas propriedades
antiinflamatórias e anticâncer que ele
tem ele também tem propriedades
dissolução de cálculos o pessoal vai ter
que tirar o demal da listinha Negra lá
dos Remédios chamados perigosos aí da
medicina alternativa
né então
concluindo o estudo do impacto dos
antibióticos na microbiota dos INSS abre
novas perspectivas para o tratamento e a
prevenção de pedras renais é importante
você cuidar da saúde do microbioma
evitar o uso indiscriminado
de
antibióticos para poder reduzir o risco
de cálculos
ok aqui a Maria tá falando foi meu irmão
que disse que a substância das ervas
voltavam e foi na NET depois se você
puder obter dele a fonte só para dar uma
checada Porque que a pessoa falou isso
aliás pessoal vou até ligar o ar
condicionado aqui tá ficando um pouco
quente aqui na sala
se você conseguir também não tem
problema viu Maria Elena se você não não
conseguir vamos próximo
artigo bem será que vocês Já pensaram
sobre o impacto dos alimentos que eles
têm na questão dos níveis de energia eu
tenho certeza que sim né então Vamos
explorar agora como
produzir os alimentos mais saudáveis
possíveis e com isso aumentar sua função
mitocondrial e a produção de energia do
corpo então o nosso corpo como vocês
devem saber funciona como um sistema que
precisa de energia para manter as suas
funções então quando a produção de
energia é insuficiente processos menos
essenciais como é o caso da digestão
reprodução e sono eles são desligados
então aumentar a produção energética
melhora Essas funções traz benefícios
Gerais paraa saúde
quando você tem uma dieta muito rica em
carboidratos e com alto teor de gordura
ruim gordura processada gordura
artificial você vai ter uma saúde
debilitada como Vocês bem sabem né então
foi apresentado como uma solução às
dietas low carb e com maior teor de
gordura natural saudável né o caso da
dieta cetogênica e a dieta
lowcarb então essas dietas são muito
interessantes para dar um choque
metabólico na pessoa que tá com
pré-diabetes ou que tá com resistência
insulínica mas muita gente tem
dificuldade de manter essas dietas a
longo prazo e tem uma razão para isso
isso não é
coincidência essas dietas são muito
promissoras no começo mas depois de
alguns meses tem que fazer um ajuste
porque depois de um tempo muitas pessoas
acabam tendo um comprometimento no
metabolismo da
glicose que é a principal forma de
produzir energia Apesar que a maioria
das pessoas hoje tem resist insulínica
tem pré-diabetes é porque elas consomem
excesso de
carboidrato depois que a pessoa faz esse
choque metabólico com a dieta cetogênica
ou low carb ela pode seim voltar a
ingerir glicose na forma de carboidrato
complexo porque o corpo dela já vai est
muito mais saudável ela vai conseguir
queimar massa glicos com muito mais
eficiência mas para isso acontecer
precisa tá fazendo atividade física
regular não deixa de ter saúde sem
atividade física
regular então pessoas que fazem dieta
cetogênica ou dieta locar por muito
tempo em alguns casos essas dietas podem
afetar a função tiroidiana que é muito
importante para produção de energia
então é importante você mudar essa dieta
depois de um tempo e buscar estratégias
para otimizar o metabolismo sem
restringir de forma exagerada os
nutrientes então é um fator muito
importante na produção de energia é o
tipo de gordura que você consome Então
existe na nossa dieta um excesso de
ácido linoleico tá linoleico que é o
ômega-6 e esse ácido linoleico ele é
encontrado principalmente em óleos
vegetais óleo de soja milho canola
girassol
e nos Estados Unidos óleo de
amendoim e óleo de algodão e também esse
óleo encontrado em alimentos
ultraprocessados e ele é um dos
principais culpados por processos ruins
metabólicos problemas metabólicos porque
ele prejudica o funcionamento
mitocondrial das usinas de energia das
células Então embora as gorduras boas
sejam muito importantes pro nosso corpo
é muito importante é essencial você
entender Quais são as gorduras boas e
quais são as gorduras ruins por muitos
anos as gorduras saturadas é por causo
da manteiga do Óleo de coco do Óleo de
abacate e também da Banha gordura animal
Eles foram demonizados
porém a verdade é que a gordura animal
sem exageros pode favorecer a saúde
celular e promover o ambiente interno
mais estruturado mais equilibrado
então é muito melhor você consumir um
óleo de coco um óleo de abacate uma
banha ou a manteiga do que ingerir óleos
de sementes processados submetidos a
solventes e altas temperaturas Então os
alimentos ricos em ácidos grassos óle
ins saturados ômega-6 como é o caso do
óleo de soja e o óleo de milho eles vão
reduzir a produção de energia e aumentar
a inflamação então é muito importante
evitar as gorduras já que você quando
sai para comer fora é praticamente
impossível Então dentro de casa você
deve utilizar os óleos que não sejam
dessa categoria aí dos ômega-6 ricos em
áro linoleico então evitar essas
gorduras ômega-6 a gerada da nossa dieta
é crucial para melhorar o metabolismo
uma maneira simples de você monitorar os
seus níveis de energia é medir a
temperatura corporal após o café da
manhã e ao meio-dia um aumento na
temperatura indica uma produção de
energia saudável hoje a gente sabe que a
maioria das pessoas tem uma baixa de
temperatura eu vi um artigo uns do anos
atrás mostrando que a população mundial
hoje tem temperatura corporal mais baixa
do que tinha muitos anos atrás e a
grande razão disso esse consumo
exagerado de óleos ômega-6 eu Nesse
artigo quando eu li ele tava
justificando essa queda de temperatura
por conta de que o ser humano estava com
menos infecções mas eu acho que essa
justificativa meio
furada Então por outro lado quando você
tem queda na temperatura corporal pós
comer isso pode ser um sinal de
disfunção metabólica causado por dietas
restritivas ou ingestão inadequada de
nutrientes certo então é interessante
que você busc aumenta a temperatura
corporal através da alimentação baixa em
omega6 e também ricas em gorduras
saudáveis azeite de oliva óleo de coco
óleo de abacate noas e castanhas
oleaginosas e a atividade física também
é muito muito importante para aumentar
essa temperatura corporal então
controlar a ingestão de carboidratos
comer os carboidratos corretos não os
refinados não os processados e comer com
moderação e escolher Fontes saudáveis
como frutas frescas e sucos naturais que
não sejam ricos em frutose
pode aumentar a produção de energia
então alimentos como bilancia
laranja são boas opções para iniciar
essa recuperação metabólica
especialmente se você tem um microbioma
intestinal comprometido as frutas Emas
são melhores ainda
né outro aspecto importante é a
qualidade dos alimentos que nós
consumimos principalmente aqueles de
origem animal então é importante que
você se preocupe com a dieta do que você
come então Então você é o que você come
você é o que a sua comida comeu né vamos
dizer assim então a dieta do Gado a
dieta da galinha que você come impacta
de forma direta a composição das
gorduras em produtos como ovos e carnes
Então você comer uma carne de uma
galinha que cisca uma galinha caipira
comer carne de um boi que comeu pasto é
muito importante alimentos de animais
alimentados com dietas ricas nessas
gorduras polinsaturadas omega6 elas vão
conter níveis elevados dessas gorduras
prejudiciais então galinha que comeu
só milho nem milho né Eles comem aquela
ração rica em
omega6 a mesma coisa e alguns gados que
são
eh tratados aí eh de maneira não
ostensiva em em grama né em Gramado em
pasto né melhor dizendo então produzir
ovos com bar teor de gorduras ômega-6 é
importante então você comer ovos de
galinha
caipira isso a gente tem até uma
assinatura de ovos lá em casa para comer
essas esses ovos ricos em
ômega-3 então é importante você buscar
esse tipo de ovos que as galinhas
comeram o alimento a ancestral delas né
comeram esses caros que comeram os
bichinhos do solo
né criar essa aves soltas que se
alimentam principalmente de
insetos isso vai reduzir os níveis de
ômega-6 acid no leico nos ovos e vai
tornar esses ovos mais
nutritivos então tem que ficar muito
atento com que você come cada vez mais
para que você tenha um metabolismo
eficiente e porque você possa também
produzir energia de forma
adequada para que essas mitocôndrias
funcionam direito
então tentem buscar galinha caipira
carne de boi que pasta porque isso faz
bastante diferença na
saúde bem Tem mais perguntas
pessoal aparentemente
não deixa eu ver se tem mais algum
artigo aqui bacana para dividir com
vocês aqui
kommer
Achei um artigo aqui
interessante a a gente encerra com esse
artigo
aqui bem Tem um estudo uma metanálise
que é analisou se os polifenois podem
melhorar a massa muscular em adultos com
sarcopenia
ok que que é sarcopenia ela é
caracterizada pela perda de massa
muscular e força com envelhecimento e
como vocês sabem é um problema do
envelhecimento é um problema de adultos
mais velhos então para enfrentar essa
condição os pesquisadores analisaram se
a suplementação com
polifenóis poderia trazer benefícios que
que é polifenóis são compostos naturais
encontrados em plantas que dá cor a
planta né então é muito comum por
exemplo na uva em várias outras plantas
e eles são conhecidos por suas
propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias Então nesse estudo
participaram 227 adultos com idades que
variaram entre 58 e 79 anos e eles foram
diagnosticados com sarcopenia então a
pesquisa incluiu homens e mulheres foi
de vários países ao mesmo tempo como
Canadá Japão Irã Coreia México
Taiwan as intervenções variaram entre 4
a 24 semanas e combinou suplementos de
polifenois em alguns casos planos de
exercícios existidos seja de força ou
multicomponentes então os resultados
revelaram uma aumento na massa muscular
entre os participantes que consumiram
polifenóis porém não houve melhorias
significativas na força ou no desempenho
físico então melhorou massa mas não
aumentou força engraçado né isso sugere
que os polifenóis podem atuar
principalmente na preservação e
crescimento muscular Mas não
necessariamente na força ou capacidade
funcional os pesquisadores destacaram
que os polifenois podem reduzir o
estresse oxidativo promover a síntese
proteínas e combater inflamações
Entretanto a inclusão de programas de
exercício em alguns estudos podem ter
influenciado os resultados isso pode
tornar difícil determinar o impacto
exclusivo dos polifenóis Então pode ter
misturado outras variáveis aí nesses
resultados então é importante ressaltar
que a qualidade dos estudos avaliados
variou porque fo uma metanálise então
juntou vários estudos Então teve três
estudos classificados como de baixa
qualidade um como moderada qualidade e
outro como alta qualidade Então essa
variação sugere que mais pesquisas
rigorosas serão necessárias para
confirmar os benefícios os polifenois
Nesse contexto do músculo fraco da
sarcopenia então concluindo Esse estudo
traz um ponto promissor sobre o papel
dos polifenóis na saúde muscular
especialmente para adultos mais
velhos então é importante combinar os
polifenóis com exercícios né Obviamente
você não vai tomar só o
polifenol é importante também você
aguardar o futuro mais investigações
nesse assunto
para saber até Quais são os polifenois
que são mais adequados aí para essa
questão de massa
muscular
Ah eu mandei minha pergunta no link de
perguntas legal vou olhar lá tá
bom vamos ver
aqui
vai não tá aparecendo aqui para mim não
ah será que é
essa pera aí deixa eu mostrar para vocês
aqui doutor alão que eu falo sobre ess
suplementos que são vírus vivos que
parasitam bactérias são bacteriófagos
né Eh que parasitam bactérias ruins no
nosso organismo tentando buscar o
equilíbrio das bactérias grampositivas
gron negativos eu tenho uma condição que
favorece o predomínio das bactérias gron
negativas Qual o fito que posso utilizar
para diminuir as Gran negativas e seja
gentil com as positivas aí você pode
usar fitoterápicos que são moduladores
de Flora tá vou falar alguns aqui para
você se comprar esse suplemento os
antibióticos naturais vão também matar
eles é mais seletivo
tá então sen tá falando aqui quais são
Olha o US bastante alho é um deles olho
de alho orégano é outro canela é outro
tá o investimento é à toa não não é à
toa mas demora para fazer efeito esses
vírus mistura tetra fage Eu tenho um
vídeo sobre esse bacteriófagos
tá é um vídeo um pouco antigo Deixa eu
ver se eu acho
aqui deixa eu achar ele aí
vê se eu acho o vídeo minutinho
só é um assunto que tem bastante tempo
que eu não estudo ten que voltar nesse
assunto
aqui porque na época eu me lembro
que não teve não teve
muita praticidade ó mostrar aqui para
vocês tá vendo aqui ah deixa eu tirar
você aqui da Peraí deixa eu tem que
mudar aqui a posição dessa bolinha aqui
pera aí deixa ver se eu consigo mexer
nela
ah Esso aqui não sei se dá para mexer
vamos
ver tá bem na na letra aqui V ver se eu
consigo
mostrar aqui ó dá para ler aqui né ó
existem vírus do bem sim existem se
chamam bacteriófagos e podem ser usados
como remédio então Então esse vídeo
Caramba já tem se anos Ô louco ó minha
cara aqui tinha pouco cabelo branco tava
mais magro
também já tem tempo hein pessoal isso
aqui vou até mandar resumir esse vídeo
aqui
tá vendo aqui vou ler para vocês ó
bacteriófagos são vírus que destróem
bactérias estudados entre 1920 e 1940 na
Europa
Oriental mas foram esquecidos após o
surgimento dos
antibióticos pesquisas com bacteriófagos
continuaram na União Soviética e país do
leste
europeu pera aí
mesmo após o advento dos
antibióticos eles podem ser usados junto
com probióticos para restaurar a flora
intestinal tratando disbiose e problemas
intestinais relacionados à imunidade
doenças autoimunes asma e alergias podem
estar associadas à barreira intestinal
prejudicada por dietas ricas em
carboidratos refinados gorduras
artificiais e
antibióticos os antibióticos matam tanto
bactérias boas quanto Ruins com exceção
dos antibióticos naturais que nós vamos
comentar daqui a pouco então eles vão
prejudicar a saúde a comprometer a
produção de vitaminas e ácidos grassos
essenciais porque sabe que a flora
intestinal é importante também produção
de vitaminas e várias substâncias
importantes como
neurotransmissores as gorduras de cadeia
curta são muito importantes paraa
alimentação do intestino grosso nos anos
40 a l Lil produziu produtos comerciais
a base de
bacteriófagos Mas eles foram esquecidos
devido à popularidade do an ticos ao
contrário dos antibióticos os
bacteriófagos são altamente seletivos
atacando apenas as cepas específicas de
bactérias sem afetar as bactérias
benéficas a fde já reconhece eles como
Seguros e Estudos mostram que
bacteriófagos favorem o crescimento de
bactérias benéficas ao eliminar as
patogênicas testes e animais confirmaram
que os bacteriófagos aumentam
significativamente o crescimento de
bactérias benéficas
e existe produtos comerciais que
combinam probióticos com bacteriófagos
deixa eu ver até se eu tô falando a
marca aqui
ver tudo bem Esses são dois dos produtos
disponíveis ó esse um produtos da época
ó Life extension Flora assist né tinha
até esquecido disso que tem esses
produtos e o Flora fe né que é desta
Arthur Andrew né aqui no Brasil eu nunca
vi Sinceramente eu acho que as
manipulações estão trabalhando já com
isso comercialmente que tem preparados
probióticos Associados aos
bacteriófagos não se esqueça de dar like
pronto só mencionei rapidamente que qual
que
é deixa eu dar uma olhada se as
manipulações estão trabalhando com
bacteriófagos rapidamente aqui
m
aparentemente não tem ainda na
manipulação
viu não temos ainda então acho que é
mais fácil procurar aquele F da Life
extension isso é exatamente isso ruber
você tem que procurar na Live
extension Beleza agora vamos voltar
aquele assunto da você falou do áo você
falou do orégano tem outras substâncias
tá que
ajudam tem outras substâncias que
ajudam o próprio própolis ele ajuda
o pau Darco é outro tem efeito
antifúngico e
antibacteriano o ácido caprílico tá que
é uma gordura de cadeia média tem ação
também moduladora de Flora você tem
também a berberina que a gente usa muito
para diabetes ela tem ação moduladora de
Flora o bitter Melon que baixa o Suca do
sangue também como a beberina também tem
efeito de modular as bactérias do
intestino o Cranberry a unha de gato que
é unca tomentosa a planta chamada
zedoária
rizoma fora o alho e o próprio orégano
que você comentou
beleza respondi a sua
dúvida
ah Ah é Letícia está na Live Ainda não
sei acho que não viu o Ana tá não acho
que ela já
saiu ó eu conheço um fenor brasileiro da
Life extension posso colocar o contato
dele no grupo pode pode colocar de nada
rerg
olha a Letícia tá respondendo aqui
ó bem eu vou entrar no site da extension
vou mostrar para vocês eu lembro que eu
estudei esse assunto há uns 6 anos para
7 anos atrás mas esse assunto meio que
morreu não não foi uma coisa que pegou
muito tração não mas tem aqui ó vou
mostrar para vocês aqui na Life
extension
aí
ó florasis probiotic Gi with phage
technology que são os bacteriófagos
né vamos olhar
aqui Ah esses produtos são outros aqui
embaixo vamos ver aqui
a o ousado só vai até aqui cadê o resto
das
informações
Ah eu acho que não tava na página
principal
não então ele tem um Blend
bacteriófagos vamos ver o overview dele
aqui ele tem sete lactobacilos e também
bif bacterium e tem os
bacteriófagos para matar as bactérias
ruins
at tem um videozinho aqui
ó vamos ver quais são esses bichos aqui
ó aqui ó aqui tem os os bacteriófagos
tetra fage Blend não mil virid cif virid
mil
virid uid essa aqui é outra Cepa aqui
são três cepas de 1 virid e uma de covid
e tem esses probióticos aqui ó bif
bacterium breve lactobacilos plantarum
bif bacter
animalis que é subespécie lactes
lactobacilos paracasei
lactobacilos rinos o acidófilos o bif
bacterium longo né e mais esses
bacteriófagos
aqui beleza
e depois a Letícia ficou de dar mais
informações pra
gente bem pessoal acho tá bom né vamos
encerrar a Live de hoje para não ficar
longo
demais agradeço imensa
eu me tirei sem querer daqui
[Música]
da bem pessoal muito obrigado por terem
acompanhado até agora eu vou encerrar
por aqui para não ficar extenso demais e
a gente se vê na próxima semana tá bom
abraço beijo no coração de vocês